[Musik]
servus und herzlich willkommen im
wunderschönen allensteig mein Name ist
Leutnant spartler ich bin geschützt
Staffel Kommandant der ersten
panzerbatterie im
aufklärungsartilleriebataillon 3 in
Mistelbach um eine Aufgabe heute ist es
das Artilleriegeschütz in
österreichischen Bundesheer etwas zu
präsentieren
vorneweg die Aufgabe der Artillerie
Truppe im österreichischen Bundesheer
ist es die Kampfgruppe welche sich vorne
im Gefecht befindet aus der Tiefe durch
indirektes Feuer zu unterstützen das
können wir leisten auf eine Entfernung
bis zu 28 km mit unserer sprengranate 94
erhöhte Reichweite wir können darüber
hinaus auch Nebelgranaten und
leuchtgranaten verschießen
verschießen können wir das Ganze durch
unsere Haubitze mit einem 155 mm Rohr
vorne haben wir eine Mündungsbremse
welche uns den Rückstoß schon ein
bisschen wegnimmt eine rauchabzugskammer
und dann das gesamte Rohr welches im
Turm eingelassen ist
was sehen wir vorne noch hier unten
drunter ist unser Motor ein V8 Zweitakt
Dieselmotor mit 440 PS der bringt uns
auf eine Geschwindigkeit von ca 60 km/h
wir haben einen Tank mit 511 Litern
Durchschnittsverbrauch 160 Liter pro 100
km und können damit ca 350 km weit
fahren wir haben grundsätzlich auf dem
Geschütz eine fünf personenbesatzung die
erste Person befindet sich direkt hier
drunter das ist der Kraftfahrer welche
zuständig dafür ist das geschützt zu
bewegen vorne sehen wir noch einmal das
maßlager welches das Rohr stabilisiert
damit eine Stabilisierung während der
Fahrt vorhanden ist wir gehen nun weiter
und schauen uns das geschützt von der
Seite an hier von der Seite sind wir
einmal das Laufwerk ganz vorne das
Antriebsrad welches dafür zuständig ist
die Leistung des Motors auf die Kette zu
bringen wir haben sechs Laufräder welche
die Kette stabilisieren hier an der
Seite sehen wir noch die nebelwurfanlage
deren Aufgabe es ist wenn wir zum
Beispiel unter Beschuss von Feind
bekommen können wir uns unter Nebel
absetzen
wir haben hier an der Seite natürlich
noch diverses Zubehör um zum Beispiel
die wischerstangen um das Rohr zu
reinigen oder Schaufel Haken was auch
immer um verschiedene Maßnahmen
durchführen zu können so wir befinden
uns nun auf dem Turm des Geschützes und
hier haben wir noch folgende Dinge wir
haben einmal vorne die Antennen für die
fernmeldeeinrichtung dann haben wir
diverses Zubehör wir haben einmal die
Abdeckplane und Tarnnetze welche
jederzeit montiert werden können und
natürlich haben wir hier noch unsere
Kampf mit einem Kaliber von 12,7
Millimeter grundsätzlich hat die
Panzerhaubitze eine Panzerung von 28 mm
Alu-Legierung welche uns eben genau von
einem solchen Kaliber schützen sollte
wir haben ebenfalls hier oben noch das
winkelfernrohr welches dafür zuständig
ist für den direkten Feuerkampf was
heißt das wie bereits angesprochen
wirken wir grundsätzlich im indirekten
richten und schießen über eine große
Meinung in den gefechtstreifen der
Kampftruppe sollte aber feinlicher
panzerfeind oder was auch immer auf uns
zu treffen in unserem feuerstellungsraum
können wir diesen mit direkten Richten
auf einem Entfernung von bis zu 1000
Meter eben mit dem genannten
winkelfernrohr bekämpfen so wir befinden
uns jetzt im Kampfraum der Panzer hier
drinnen befinden sich insgesamt vier
Personen wer gibt beginnen mit dem K1
dem Geschütz Formen welche sich hier
befindet und mit dem richtgriff das Rohr
der Erhöhung und der Seite nachrichtet
dass die Granate auch das gewünschte
Ziel trifft direkt daneben steht der
ladekanon hier der nimmt die Granaten
aus den Halterungen für die Granaten
heraus und temptiert diese sprich wir
können unsere Sprenger Granaten auf
Aufschlag verschießen oder auch auf
Verzögerung wenn wir auf eine Deckung
zum Beispiel schießen
der nimmt die Granate legt sie in die
Ladeschale der ansatzvorrichtung bedient
dann die ansatzvorrichtung so dass durch
den schubteller die Granate ins Rohr
reingeschoben wird
dann schauen wir uns noch die andere
Seite an
auf dieser Seite befindet sich zum einen
der Geschützführer auf dem
Geschützführer Sessel der führt die
geschützt Bedienung und führt auch den
artilleristischen Feuerkampf auf
geschützt Ebene er bedient das war von
einsatzsystem kommen mit new generation
wo die ganzen schieß Elemente alles über
Datenfunk dem Geschäftsführer zugesendet
wird er bedient die Navigationsanlage wo
die schießelemente dann an den richtigen
geschickt werden und selbstverständlich
bediente auch die Fernmelder
Einrichtungen um stetig Verbindung zu
der übergeordneten Ebene zu halten
darüber hinaus befindet sich hier noch
der K2 der Verschluss Kanonier der
bedient den Verschluss legt die
Treibladung ins Rohr ein
bedient auch den Abzug und darüber
hinaus beim direkten Richten schaut er
durchs winkelfernrohr und hat hier
ebenfalls einen richtgriff wie schon
zuvor der K1 um so den Feind bekämpfen
zu können
so das war's jetzt mit einer groben
Einführung in die panzerbitze und jetzt
der Beobachter wartet schon ich würde
sagen jetzt fahren wir in die
Feuerstellung und schießen
[Musik]